7 le meurtre du petit philippe bertrand
patrick henry l'assassin devait
reconstituer le drame ce matin dans la
petite chambre d'un modeste hôtel de la
rue fortier à 3 un important dispositif
policier avait été mis en place pour
éviter tout incident de cette
reconstitution les enquêteurs espéraient
beaucoup et notamment la réponse à la
question
patrick henry at il tué le jeune
philippe bertrand avec préméditation ou
dans un instant de panique mais jean
pire à bout cette reconstitution a été
finalement décevante pour les enquêteurs
en raison de l'attitude du meurtrier
patrick henry avait peur de la foule
mais ce matin les habitants de trois ne
se sont même pas dérangés
la reconstitution a duré à peine trois
quarts d'heure patrick henry que vous
voyez sur ces images sortant
précipitamment de la brasserie des
charmilles a refusé de refaire le geste
meurtrier sur le mannequin que lui
présentait les enquêteurs il n'a pas
voulu non plus répondre aux questions
que lui posaient le juge d'instruction
mademoiselle gérard dans cette chambre
où depuis son horrible crime
tout est resté en place comme figé dans
l'horreur patrick henry à un mouvement
de recul face à l'entrée de la chambre
l'angle droit dans lequel les policiers
ont retrouvé le corps de l'enfant près
de la porte
le poste de télévision avec lequel il
tenta voilà six mois de distraire
philippe au cours de la reconstitution
patrick henry évident de s'approcher des
meubles de manipuler les quelques objets
très lent dans la chambre la cuisine à
plusieurs reprises les magistrats les
policiers répètent leurs ordres patrick
henry prostré semble ne rien entendre
les points importants comme gérard
souhaitait vérifier n'ont pas pu être
vérifiées en partie si sur le plan
matériel n'est pas par les déclarations
de patrick henry qui a refusé de se
prêter à la reconstitution trop quel
était-il pas on peut pas vous dire grand
chose mais mal il a très mal supporté
aujourd'hui non pas la reconstitution
puisqu'il n'ya pas une reconstitution
proprement parler mais la simple
évocation des faits qui sont déroulés
précisément dans la pièce où tout ça
vient de se faire élire sont quand même
est-ce que son émotion quand même à
percer pour ce qu'une chaise roulante
est-ce qu'on a servi dante il était
manifestement bouleverser cette
reconstitution n'aura apporté aucune
réponse sur trois points qui demeurent
mystérieux patrick henry avait il un
complice at il
donner à l'enfant des somnifères et
surtout question essentielle at-il
prémédité ce crime
insoutenable